well president Trump goes to West Point
this morning to speak at the graduation
ceremony at the US Military Academy but
he's rescheduling another big event a
campaign rally in Oklahoma originally
planned for June 19th the day known as
Juneteenth marks the end of slavery in
the US Nikole Killion is traveling with
the president who is spending the
weekend at his New Jersey Golf Club
Nicole good morning why the reversal
make it more yeah good morning to you
Michelle well president Trump says that
he is now switching dates because he
doesn't want this rally to conflict with
the African American observance of
Juneteenth in the meantime his visit to
West Point today is going to look a lot
different in this new era of COBIT with
graduating cadets wearing masks and
those sharing the dais with the
president being tested for coronavirus
in his first commencement address to
West Point today the White House says
President Trump will congratulate cadets
for their amazing accomplishments more
than a thousand will be socially distant
for the outdoor celebration which comes
as tensions rise with the military as a
commissioned uniformed officer it was a
mistake
several White House sources tell CBS
News they were surprised by this
videotaped apology from mark Milley
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff he
said he should not have accompanied the
president to st. John's Church where
protesters were forcibly removed before
a photo-op
my presence in that moment and in that
environment created a perception of the
military involved in domestic politics
the president said Milley statement
didn't bother him if that's the way they
feel I think this fund I have good
relationships with the military in
Pennsylvania vice president Mike Pence
told CBS news radio Steven Portnoy why
he didn't walk across Lafayette Square
with the president that day I was at the
White House and I was actually
encouraged to stay at the White House
out of an abundance of caution
late Friday the president changed course
on a controversial decision to hold his
first rally since the pandemic in Tulsa
Oklahoma on June 10th it's a day that
typically commemorates the end of
slavery but some African American
lawmakers called the timing
disrespectful given the city's historic
race riots the president claimed that
was not his intent was that on purpose
no think about it as a celebration don't
think about it as the president tweeted
many of my African American friends and
supporters have reached out to suggest
that we consider changing the date out
and he says the rally will now happen
Saturday June 20th to honor their
request he says more than 200,000 ticket
requests have been received but keep in
mind
anyone who RSVPs for this rally has to
acknowledge the potential risk of
exposure to coronavirus and agree not to
sue the campaign in the event they get
sick Jeff okay Nicole thank you very
much